[MUSIC PLAYING]
A couple years ago, I got
involved with some people.
Not Java coders.
No.
This isn't a talk about Java.
These people were into fashion.
Now, that's a bit out of
the stereotype for a coder.
But what's a coder going to do?
Well, I studied.
And it was interesting,
these principles of fashion.
Fast forward, and we're
working on our next game.
We need an art style, but
we're short on artists.
So what's a coder going to do?
Well, I studied.
And surprisingly, it
was all very familiar.
It turns out that the
principles of fashion
are just the principles
of aesthetics.
And the principles of
aesthetics are universal.
So if you learn something
about dressing well,
then you learn something
about decorating your living
room, choosing a font
for your business card,
and yes, improving the
visuals of your next game.
So let me tell you
about what I learned.
I learned that this is wrong.
So wrong for so many reasons.
But one of those reasons is
that there is no contrast.
Now, these outfits
have contrast.
Notice how the colors
define recognizable
shapes, so the eye knows
what it's looking at.
Notice too how the
details draws your eye in,
so that the eye knows what
it's supposed to be looking at.
Now, this same principle
applies to games.
In Prune, at the start of
the level, all of the colors
are solid and all of the
shapes are geometrical.
Then, when a tree
starts to grow,
it starts to add a little
detail to the scene.
And at the end of
the level, there's
an explosion of
detail and colors.
This addition of contrast
is immensely rewarding
aesthetically.
It's like you are aesthetically
completing the scene.
So contrast and shapes,
details and color.
The eye needs contrast.
OK.
So contrast is good, right?
Then why is this so wrong?
There's no cohesion here.
There's no focus.
Everything is vying
for your attention.
These outfits have repetition.
Notice the repetition in
the colors, the shapes,
even the formalness of
the pieces is repeated.
Now, this need for repetition
applies to all visuals.
In Alto, the
triangles of the trees
are repeated in the mountains.
The circle of the sun
is repeated in one
of the trees on the right.
The overall color is
consistent, and it
frames the one
strongly contrasting
shape-- your character.
So repetition and shapes,
colors, and styles.
It unifies your look and
allows you to focus attention.
Now, for colors,
you can go wild.
That's what Keita Takahashi
does in his games.
And some people dress like
this, too, which is amazing.
But there's a definite method
behind colors like this.
Colors like this are
hard, which explains
why most of the people in
this room are wearing blue.
But colors can be easy, too.
Sometimes you just see
a color combination
that you really love, so all
you have to do is remember that.
And then you can
wear it yourself,
or you can use it in your
next game, like in Journey.
They didn't use blue for the
sky and brown for the sand.
They chose colors that were
far more vibrant and impactful.
And they knew those
colors would work,
because they were probably
wearing them themselves
just the other day.
Or in Monument Valley.
You can see how the
bold color palettes
add to the emotion of the game.
When you look at the
most beautiful games,
it's clear that they're not
driven by a technical mindset.
They're not simply showing off
the latest lighting techniques,
for instance.
They're driven, instead,
by a deep appreciation
for the principles
of aesthetics,
like contrast, repetition,
color, contrast, repetition,
and color.
You can learn these
principles yourself, too,
if you practice them every day.
Here are three coders at
Google who do just that.
And they don't practice
aesthetics by studying.
No.
They simply consider
each morning which
shoes go well with these pants.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]